foreign
's with us in Chattanooga hi Marie
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi it's really
good how are you doing better than we
deserve what's up in your world
so short question how do I
without them coming to live with my
husband and I so why is that your job my
husband is
because
um
I
my parents don't have anything safe for
retirement and for various reasons
um my that I experienced growing up my
husband and I are not okay with them
living with us in the future
um why is it your job to take care of
them
because I
I agree that they're honest why is it
your job to take care of them
if they go in the street why is it your
job to get them out of the street
because they're my parents and I love
them I don't want to see them homeless
okay
it's not your here's where it's a desire
it's not your job it's something that
you like to do want to do and are
choosing to do
so don't don't pose the question in your
mind as if you are somehow forced
ethically or morally or spiritually into
doing this
now why why would your parents not have
any money why would they not at least
have social security
they would have social security but
um they're too irresponsible to pay
their house payment
they don't have a house right now
um where do they live now yeah
they are in the process of moving to
another state my father just got a new
job and
um with various moves in the past couple
of years all of the equity that they had
built up in the house that they owned
when I was growing up has been depleted
the reason that I feel like I want to
give back and I don't want to put my
parents into this situation is because
um
I'm not saying that it's my fault I know
it's their fault you didn't put them in
you just said I put them in this
situation you didn't put them in the
situation here's the thing Marie the
reason we're getting you on your
language is because the way what you
speak is a reflection of what the way
your heart feels so even though you're
saying I know I know I know you don't
you don't because you keep saying it
it'll be if they end up like this it'll
be my fault I have to be the one to help
them if I don't do it no like you keep
putting that on yourself and it's so
important to make sure your language is
clear and the facts about this are clear
going in how old are your mom and dad
they are 63. okay and your dad just got
a new job they're moving to another
state what's your dad going to be making
280.
000 a year
yes the reason is my parents have
um
my grandfather decided that he was going
to pay for my
um father and my uncle to go through
school and so my parents decided that
they were going to do that for us
so I don't have any debt because of that
and I am super super grateful for that
and I want to experience I'm sorry
somewhere I got confused stop stop you
just went off the you just went off to
another planet
um I asked you if you're what your
father was going to be making in his new
job
dollars
yes
Noah's has he always earned an income
or is this just
it has been around the 200 000 mark this
answers the question this answers the
question okay stop you don't need to do
anything
you need to look at your mom and dad and
say I love you
bye
you you know people that make 300 000 a
year and can't figure out a way to have
housing aren't your problem
this is asinine Marie that you even have
the feeling that you have to prepare for
the homelessness of someone making 280
000 your family is dysfunctional if I
dump some crap on you and what do you
make by the way Marie
um I bring in 4 000 a month and my
husband brings in 36.00 look no no no no
no not in the world
nope your dad makes 280 and the two of
you together don't make 90 and you
somehow got that this is your job
to prepare for their homelessness it's
not going to be making two they're not
going to be making 280 indefinitely once
that my father is unable to work they
won't have anything built up and since
that's their fault okay with them living
with us that's their fault I'm aware of
that let me tell you the number of
dollars I'm gonna give this guy zero
Marie they don't have to live with you
look they don't have to live with you if
he screws up a 280 000 income and ends
up homeless that is not on you
but it's not on you do not need to do
this I don't know what in the world has
gotten into you and by the way they're
not going to end up homeless it the
worst case scenario they're going to be
these people land on their feet
repeatedly though yeah they lose
everything and get a job at 63 making
300 Grand this guy lands on his feet
like an alley cat
and he's got his daughter over here
making 40K worried about his
homelessness yeah
this is hey kiddo really you need to sit
down and see it you need to see a
counselor yeah because this is this is
deep stuff you are you are reflecting
back weird crap that happened in your
house growing up and I don't know what
it was but how in the world your mama
ends up a travel agent for guilt trips
on you is beyond me
I mean there is no possible way you end
up taking care of these people not in my
book nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope Dave dad does cocaine so
I have to take care of him no you don't
well you have to honor your father and
your mother the Bible says yes we honor
the position of fatherhood and
motherhood we do not honor the use of
cocaine
there's two different things if you
misbehave with 280 Grand to the point
you don't take care of your own
household that is not on your kids yeah
it's not
because I
I heard and it has to be addressed there
is a burden that kids grown kids grown
adult children face when they see okay
your parents they're not doing what they
should do and even if you know it's not
my job like it's not my responsibility
there is a part of guilt that you feel
that's like okay
that's like okay am I gonna be the one
that's gonna watch them you know go by
the wayside am I gonna let them live
like this and you some point you do have
to make pieces if you're a kind person
people that you love are hurting
you it's not it's not fun to watch
people you love doing stupid things if
you're a kind person if you're a good
person but doesn't I it doesn't make me
happy the people that I love are doing
stupid things but it also doesn't make
me responsible yeah you have to make
peace with the fact that you're not
responsible for adult choices you know
Henry cloud has this wonderful book
called Boundaries you need to memorize
it